the big fella and i see that you have
some of your
is that your part of your wing over
there no this is my hulk nose i'm only
going to bring it out if we win
chuckling about to say something you
never heard me say before i'm good
lopez is six foot six in the paint
yes in the paint so you know last year i
mean last game they had
14 points in the paid in the first half
today they got 44 points you've been
saying this
at all times no first three games they
did dominate the point but last game
we don't know what happened right here
jrue holiday bully ball
listen if you take take close shots high
percentage shots
and most of the time they're going to go
in further you're out from the basket if
you're not shooting well
long rebounds other team gets the
rebound you got to stay in the paint
this guy right here is dominating i i
don't think i haven't seen him do that
in four or five years and right here
the sed the show oh my god really
dominating point but to again to to
chuck's point
the hawks are around so i'm gonna put on
my lucky beak and i'm gonna give out the
call
let me hear it so they can hear me oh
that's a muddy thing a money beat that's
right
magic city coming back home i didn't
mean to give it away i just
noticed it sitting there of chuck bucks
with a what is that
an elastic ear holder
all right so my guy eric so what's your
arts and crafts do you have a